let's jump into this first story from
apnews.com Garland appoints special
counsel to investigate Biden docs
attorney general Merrick Garland on
Thursday appointed a special counsel to
investigate the presence of classified
documents found at President Joe Biden's
home in Wilmington Delaware and at an
unsecured office in Washington dating
from his time as vice president Robert
Herr a one-time U.S attorney appointed
by former president Donald Trump will
lead the investigation and plans to
begin his work soon his appointment
marks a second time in a few months that
Garland is appointed a special counsel
an extraordinary fact that reflects the
Justice Department's efforts to
independently conduct high-profile
probes in an exceedingly heated
political environment both of those
investigations the early one involving
Trump and documents recovered from his
Mar-A-Lago estate in Florida relate to
the handling of classified information
though there are notable differences
between those cases I love how the media
really really wants to make sure
everybody knows there's notable
differences but they don't ever quite
bring up the fact that PolitiFact ran
this story quote the minute the
president speaks about it to someone he
has the ability to declassify anything
at any time without any process mostly
true reports PolitiFact so if that's the
case what is the issue with Donald
Trump's documents so uh well I'm curious
I mean we I think everyone's heard our
thoughts on this I'm wondering what you
guys think you know like I don't think
the issues that at least from what we
see with the with the search warrant
wasn't classification I think the issue
was the fact that he a obstructed the
investigation
allegedly and be the Espionage Act which
says you can't have defense documents in
your possession when the government
needs them
so so I I don't think I don't think
that's what they're trying to get him on
Trump yeah I don't think they're trying
to get him on on the classification
issue maybe that changes but from what
I've read I I think they're going after
him because he basically had government
documents I think one of the big
challenges with the Trump thing is that
we've heard from the Trump side of
things and from early reports that they
they were cooperating but they did let
them come in and it was actually the
FBI's own lock so so the FBI comes in
and says hey you have these documents
just make sure you lock them up and
they're like you got it boss then the
FBI comes back later smashes the lock
and takes the documents yeah so so what
happened was so January he leaves office
in May the National Archives is like Hey
listen we believe you have documents and
I don't know if they gave him a list of
documents they thought he had but they
said you have documents where you'd like
them back and then it took seven more
months Trump's lawyers I think it was in
December of 2021 said okay well we we
found some documents then in January
they said here's 15 boxes of documents
and and the following months I think it
was February of 2022 the National
Archives comes back and says we still
didn't get all of them we you still have
more we need more documents and they go
back and forth back and forth and
apparently National Archives wasn't
satisfied with how Trump's team was
cooperating so they got a grand jury
subpoena in the spring and then
they went they visited it visited
Mar-A-Lago and Trump's team allowed them
to search the basement I believe the
basement storage room and they came out
there with more documents and the lawyer
signs the signs a declaration saying
we've searched the entire place no more
documents are here
then it turns out there were more there
are more documents but I suppose the
issue is the president has plenary
declassification powers
as the president he is the end-all
be-all of what is classified or what
isn't yeah but you also got to look at
like what's the damage to the country so
like is he taking compartment mentalized
documents that there's one copy of that
somebody else in government now maybe in
the Biden Administration might need for
whatever they're whatever they're
working on I I is it a danger to the
country and and we don't know we don't
know if that's the case or not but I I I
think that like to to figure that out
would be big to just understand the
situation I I can agree I mean if if
there's like a single copy of it they're
like whoa what happened to these files
would be really really bad but that'd be
really really bad outside of trump just
having them because what are we doing
not having important copies but that
still doesn't answer the question of the
so the the reason the president can
declassify anything instantly is because
imagine he's negotiating with Vladimir
Putin to like get out of Ukraine and
then he has to go there and be like well
you know I would negotiate on troop
positioning in Nate in in Poland or
whatever but uh it's classified so I
can't tell you about it like that makes
no sense he needs to literally be like
okay here's where our our shipments and
troops are going in we'll take those out
if you take this so he has to be able to
do that so this looks just overtly
political but even so outside of that I
can certainly understand an argument of
like the greater good like whether or
not Trump has the power to do it you
know maybe we should get those documents
back but then why pursue a criminal
investigation and then you get the media
coming out and saying Trump is under
criminal investigation but Joe Biden is
his documents are facing a special
counsel well they don't even say he's
facing it I think with Trump though
I don't think he was under criminal
investigation until he didn't turn over
the documents at the national Army he
doesn't have to well he does if the
government says they're there but but if
the president has it even there's not
not classified he still has to turn them
over if the National Archive says these
are government documents we need them
back they're not your personal documents
I suppose I can understand the argument
you're making that their property of but
if they but that's that's an argument
where we'd have to actually look into
determine whether or not he made copies
of these documents but my understanding
was that he has copies of them as the
president and some of the documents were
like his presidential briefings and
stuff like that which if if he can
declassify then he can have but but at
any rate if that was the case pursuing
criminal charges because he's like I
disagree on whether you own this piece
of paper is is kind of it's kind of
silly yeah is it so you can't have
copies of compartmentalized documents so
like classified documents there could be
multiple copies and several people could
either but if they're compartmentalized
there's only usually one cup one copy as
far as I understand so if he had that he
would have had to have taken it out of
the compartment or wherever it's at and
brought it back to Mar-A-Lago and then
somebody else can't gain access to that
so there actually is only one copy as
far as I know well I guess we have to
get into the what all of the documents
are yeah and then when were the
documents taken if they were taken after
he was no January 20th when he was
leaving the White House
maybe he was no longer president when he
told them so you know you need that
information and I'm pretty sure they
have copy machines in Washington DC to
be a little facetious this year but more
importantly it's kind of convenient that
the burden of proof is it's classified
we can't tell you but there's only one
of us and we really really needed it for
what we can't tell you yeah so we will
never know we for me personally I don't
think we should give the burden of Doubt
to the doj that clearly is very
political especially when it came to
what happened with Biden they found
Biden's documents on November 2nd a week
before the midterm elections we're now
hearing about it I think this would have
had an effect on the election and I
think this is why the doj has been
politicized because this is one clear
example of it and when not just that
it's uh the vice president and Hillary
Clinton and Secretary of State separate
instances do not have the power of
declassification well so vice president
does it so there's a 2003 executive
order by George Bush I believe I believe
Obama had another executive office an
order in 2 2009 which says the vice
president and the president can both
classify documents and the vice
president can declassify documents that
he classified and
also if he is deemed a super in a
supervisory role over the agent who
classified it he can declassify it so
I mean if there are random documents
maybe he didn't have it it depends what
a supervisory role is and I don't think
there's really a clear definition of
that is it vice president of the second
in the executive branch a supervisor of
you know an agent in the CIA we don't
know like I don't know I think that's
something that would have to be
determined by a judge or you know I do
have this I pulled it up this is from
the Washington Times a March 2003
executive order signed by George W bush
empowered the vice president to classify
sensitive materials that same executive
order grants declassification powers to
quote the official who authorized the
original classification or a supervisor
official under the executive order vice
presidents are granted the power to
declassify documents they classified
themselves but it's unclear If the vice
president would be viewed as a
supervisory official with the ability to
declassify sensitive documents from the
CIA and other intelligence agencies I
just think it's really convenient that
we got probably 300 articles arguing
that Donald Trump would have to Forfeit
any office or that he was disqualified
for having classified document literally
not even the argument of you know
compartmentalization it was like if he
had classified documents he violated the
records act or whatever and then as soon
as it happens with Joe Biden it happens
twice all of a sudden there's a debate
over well you know actually the vice
president the president can declassify
things it sounds like a cop-out yeah I I
think it kind of depends on intent right
so like did Trump take them purposely
out of out of the White House or
wherever and keep store them at
Mar-A-Lago I I think we know more of his
intent just because the fact that he
refused to turn them over knowing that
he had I disagree I mean the documents
were in boxes of random things like like
briefings and Time Magazine clippings it
really does sound like in both instances
of Biden and Trump they had boxes of
paperwork they just carried out not
realized what was in it yeah I I think
until we see more information you have
to assume that he didn't he didn't
intentionally do it right neither of
them intentionally did it unless you
have you know witnesses that saw him or
heard him say you know no we have to
keep these we don't want to turn them
over to that National Archives because
they're mine I believe they're mine the
government shouldn't have a right to
take them so so I think we have to hear
the information that comes out we have
to see the evidence and I guess we'll
eventually see that I don't know how
long it's going to take I'd like to
repeal this executive order in the
meantime George Bush gave Dick Cheney
way too much power he let him run the
war basically let him put his
Halliburton company in Iraq to make all
this money and this stupid stupid rule
that he gave the vice president with no
command Authority the ability to
classify and declassifying those insane
yeah well Dick Cheney was pretty much
the president uh he's pretty much
calling the shots here let's just be
real here but the little that we know
about these classified documents and I
don't think we're going to learn more
about them because the doj clearly is
very political they clearly have a side
here so I don't see them releasing any
kind of more information here I mean
we'll see what happens I'm always
skeptical but the few things that we do
know is that they were they were related
to Ukraine to Iran and the United
Kingdom so these were specific documents
dealing with uh intelligence foreign
Services what's happening
internationally so I I think with with
that context especially with with where
they were located at a think tank that's
connected to Chinese money there is some
possible questions here about what
information was shared who got it
especially with the big business ties
between Ukraine and the bidens the
Chinese government and the bidens I
think there's a lot more room for a lot
more corruption here uh especially with
you know Biden being a career politician
rather than Donald Trump who's kind of
been obfuscated away from politics and
kind of pushed away from everybody
that's my initial kind of reaction what
do you guys think I I think that I
definitely agree I think there should be
a special counsel and there should be an
investigation so I I think they're
handling both both Trump and Biden the
correct way special counsels uh I mean
you can say that the doj is politicized
but it's a it's an independent special
counsel being appointed I think he was
actually appointed by Trump uh this her
guy I think the Attorney General that's
uh or overseeing it in in one of the
jurisdictions was appointed by Trump but
I don't know about the special counsel
guy to be honest I think her I think her
was a trump nominee or Trump appointment
I don't know I guess what's the name her
Robert her yeah so like I think that I
think we just got to wait and see and
and I hope they investigate Biden just
as rigorously as they they're
investigating Trump and we figure this
out I I don't think I don't think many
Democrats disagree that that we should
figure out all the facts behind this and
it could be good it could be bad
whatever it is I think it's important we
know right thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time